this episode was proudly made possible
by Subaru you know a lot of people lose
sleep every night because they think the
world is going to hell and that things
are getting worse if we have a mass
media that operates under the principles
if it bleeds it leads
and you can understand why that is the
case I mean we have inherited an
amygdala in our brain which is the part
of the brain that's responsible for
triggering an alarm during moments in
which we have to flee or neutralize a
perceived threat this has been
biologically selected for because it
it's helped us survive over time so you
can understand why we are glued to the
TV screen because negative news and
creating a sort of self amplifying
feedback loop of doom and gloom but
again my friends look a little bit
closer peek behind the curtain and what
you actually find is a lot more
reassuring according to the work of
Steven Pinker wrote the book the better
angels of our demons and has a viral TED
talk called the myth of violence the
world has actually been getting better
for hundreds of years today according to
paper the chances of a man dying at the
hands of another man on a global scale
are the lowest than they've ever been in
the history of mankind listen to that
again the chances of a man dying at the
hands of another men are the lowest that
they've ever been Hans Rosling a
statistician and data visualizer has
gone viral with a series of talks
including a TED talk in which he Maps
every nation on earth by every
measurable indicator of quality of life
it shows that every nation is improving
even the ones on the very bottom are
doing better than they used to be
so again when seen as a whole you see
the man-machine civilization
increasingly leveraging its tools to
address the grand problems of humanity I
mean there was an article recently where
New York Times that said that the most
extreme form of poverty around the world
is actually almost eliminated I mean I
would never know this was in the New
York Times unbelievable or a 2010 United
Nations Development essay cited by Bill
Clinton from Time magazine in an article
titled
a case for optimism in which he says
forget about the info halves and the
info nots and he cited the cellphone as
the greatest invention in history to
pull people out of poverty so again
these are just a numerous amount of
examples there's infinitely more but the
world is on the right track it's not
utopia as Steven Johnson was say but
it's leaning that way and I'm not just
saying that cuz I'm an optimist these
are data-driven facts
you
be sure to check out second chance
Subaru at revision3.com Subaru